I wanted to write about men in crisis so
Zurich sees the younger protagonist is
admit quarter life and his father is a
midlife almost exactly and so I also
wanted to put them into a time of crisis
like the post 9-11 era and examine men
under pressure and and then look at
their conflicts and put you know and
examine their conflicts in a larger
sense I look at how much global turmoil
and historical turmoil has contributed
to some of their interpersonal conflict
it became a kind of thesis for the novel
that sometimes the conflicts of men even
in one family weren't really about their
issues but sometimes about what was
going on in the news or what was going
on in history books I take a lot of
pains to examine some of the ancient
kings in Persian history and then merge
that with some of the prime characters
and sort of 911 the story